[Musique]
comme beaucoup de nos clients et
collaborateurs j'ai évidemment moi même
été très choqués par ces images donc
dans ces conditions il était pour nous
il envisageable qu'ils continuent à
représenter l'enseigne donc ils nous ont
quittés ils ont quitté l'enseigne
magasin est fermé aujourd'hui il
réouvrira demain avec une nouvelle
direction
une entreprise aujourd'hui quelle que
soit sa taille peut se retrouver
confronté un enjeu médiatique qui la
dépasse il est très difficile
l'élite du moins de plus en plus
difficile de faire la séparation entre
ce qui est antérieur et ce qui est
extérieur à l'entreprise
pourquoi parce que les salariés parce
que les acteurs qui constitue
l'entreprise communique dans
l'entreprise communique au nom de
l'entreprise et aussi des formes de
communication personnels qui viennent
aujourd'hui se télescoper sur le web
si le migrant force le passage c'est
très simple on appellera la gendarmerie
qui aura l'obligation d'intervenir de
prendre en charge le migrant qui est en
situation illégale en france et la
justice fera la suite
[Musique]